soon after Valentin saitarly moved his
Tech startup from the Silicon Valley to
Miami he knew it was the right decision
all these people are just random people
have met at events and they were so
excited and motivated to help you
um
is it related to social environment
because you wake up in the morning go to
a beautiful Street where it's clean and
you have a nice mood cytarli is the
founder of an artificial intelligence
company called p-r-a-i and he's part of
a growing number of AI startups moving
to Miami lured not only by the office
views but also Miami's business friendly
climate and low taxes
Miami is a city that wants to position
itself as more than just a Beach
vacation destination and also marketing
itself as the crypto Hub of America in
2021 it launched Miami coin its own
branded cryptocurrency and FTX once one
of the world's largest crypto exchanges
bought the naming rights to the downtown
Sports Arena
Miami's gamble on cryptocurrency is so
far garnered mixed results Miami coin
lost over 90 percent of its value in a
little under a year and FTX it went
completely bankrupt and its name was
removed from the arena add it all up and
it's perhaps a cautionary tale for AI
great job Miami is betting big on
education to provide the workforce
Miami-Dade College this year opened a
first of its kind AI Learning Center the
program hopes to start graduating up to
1 000 students a year to work at local
AI startups these kinds of companies are
looking for talent at Miami-Dade College
is really embracing that challenge to
come up with new uh to train the work
the next Generation really of the
workforce that's coming online with
artificial intelligence it's way too
early to tell if Miami will really
become the AI Hub it aspires to be or if
it's just an artificial aspiration
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera Miami